[Music]
have you guys ever witnessed strong
parenting no person what does that mean
I saw a [ __ ] throw vegetables at
his son
what kind of veggies I was mad was his
son Tommy no he was scolding his son and
they're all eating hotpot and he grabbed
some vegetables and chucked it at his
son and we all looked over and I was
like oh [ __ ] this fool why would you
wasting vegetable how young was the job
he was a kid like he was like ten nine I
was picturing for some reason a teenager
which I think thorne visits here you're
right if he was 15 I would have been
like okay well this photo went viral on
Facebook no strong physically strong
bear just carrying her kids so the kids
but is right there holding the camera on
the side where are those is she doing
push-ups playing oh is that a pack of
hot dogs just let me explain
listen these are fingers she was holding
from this wait where is it
where'd it go oh it's oom did too much
but in just these other photos you could
see like part of her child's head down
here it's like a little white kid okay
here though you could see this mom what
the hell did you just zoom in more
disciplinarians she's carrying one kid
on her side and then going in the purse
well the purse is kind of make it look
like a weird illusion but this kid is on
all fours doing push-ups yeah little
girl doing push-ups
it's a boy huh just a video
no is it is it one black kid and one
white kid that's what it looks like
no it looks like it's or it seems to be
both black kids or her kids
oh so the other white looking kids the
black yo - you bet I think that cuz it
looks like a white kids like like this
shirts up like that the white kid well
that is not what we're focusing on see
you
let me read to you the caption of this
Facebook post so Molly posted Oh God
from Texas she said so the woman in the
Hobby Lobby bathroom Hobby Lobby back if
my hands weren't full of children I
would have applauded you yeah I love it
as your son gave you the back talk of
the century you stayed calm and
collected while adding 10 more push-ups
to his already growing number it's
awesome we need more parents like you
who aren't afraid to parent their own
children because of what someone else
might think he said mama this is a
bathroom floor grow she said maybe you
shouldn't have been acting obnoxious
they have so for a reason ten more
random woman of Hobby Lobby I love you
keep on raising them boys rights and
then she adds like a little - I have
since found a mom through the power of
social media and she promptly thanked me
for posting this she says she
appreciates the support and positive
comments and we're hoping to grab cut
grab coffee sometime supervising
push-ups that is this is Texas right
yeah so I mean I mean like Texas culture
is different from like organ culture and
LA culture from from watching king of
the hill it's definitely different in
Texas yeah dude it'd be crazy though
she's like she also elaborated and like
her son contracted coronal virus was
talking about before he was right he was
right yeah because I think we all
thought was gonna be a how dare this
mother make her son do push-ups you know
that's so mild
I like that I've seen actual abuse yeah
smack the [ __ ] out of their kids and the
grocery store all that [ __ ] right this
is what Molly says she said like she was
explaining what strong parenting means
to her she said parent first friend
later when you've asked your child for
something like the simple simple request
to behave or to clean up after playing
and it's not being fulfilled
whatever consequence you've stated for
their lack of actions must follow no
must be falling through firmly you can't
back down so she says that she
recognizes that push-ups nut might not
be for everyone but whatever discipline
you do decide on you have to stand
behind it with a firm but sometimes do
sit-ups - or lunges burpees oh yeah
that's punishment for anyone
yeah but I got what she means by strong
parenting cuz it's I don't know man it
gets hard to be a strong parent
especially if you didn't have a very
strong parent cuz like for example my
mom if I pushed her enough she would
Bend like no matter what like if I asked
her like oh can I sleep over my friend's
house she says no three times I know by
the fourth time she's gonna say yes I
just have to ask and ask and ask oh yeah
and so for my little brothers like great
like helping raise them I'm like mom
you've gotta stop saying yes to
everything cuz she just wants them to
just shut up like why aren't you helping
your brothers would be like yo here's
five great mom hacks that you just have
find out right no because rate her with
the age gap was that big where I was
like their second long so I had to help
discipline them too and like help mold
them into good people but they know mom
was probably going back on her own word
so I made it hard for you to be the
second month exactly and that's the
reason why I would get so upset with my
mom because I'm like you're making it
harder on me like I'm trying to help you
but you just give in to any requests so
that's not good parents and then you
look like a bad person
yeah but what if all your kids requests
are pretty reasonable request you scream
every day no no like a reasonable
request like hey mom did I have
reasonable I have protein with veggies
tonight yeah I mean like one of the they
say reasonable [ __ ] do you have to like
10% job no link it rule to not say yes
to everything
no I know but I'm scared yes or the bad
thing okay got it
yeah cuz I'm saying that's lazy
parenting really it's just to like give
in and just give your kid whatever they
want just to shut up like that's how you
get like you get really just entitled
ass people yeah you don't say what you
do don't you
what do you do when you get a kid who
gets whatever they want no matter what
what do you mean like they only arrive
at your doorstep like they [ __ ] know
Matt like they're difficult as well like
we're taking care of someone else's kid
they're very determined and if they put
their mind to it they're gonna go for it
I beat Union apiece this your childr so
we need to be Stern any
stand your ground like my mom even if I
took her abusive ways away
I think her resilience well she would
out resilient you yeah so if it's gonna
be like let's say I go hey can I have
chocolate she says no and I'm not gonna
leave this pantry and tell I get my
chocolate it's like all right she'll
probably stay in that pantry for 72
hours you're standing there like let's
like I have a staring contest
let's go mom I'd be like my waste of
time
yeah I got [ __ ] to do I'm sorry take the
[ __ ] chocolate get cavities are
wiping your ass out of the pantry that's
what's happening um one thing that my
parents did that I remember to this day
is um we went to Toys R Us and I
remember I was getting a reward for
something good grades or something like
that right and they're like okay you get
to choose one thing and I couldn't
decide between the Rock and Roll
Donatello action figure or Ninja Turtles
poster right and I was so torn I'll go
with the poster dude I was like my god
III so I chose the toy way better I
chose the toy and because the and you
know Toys R Us there's always kids going
out of there screaming crying cuz any
get what they wanted yeah and they were
like okay and when we got to the
register they're like because you didn't
whine we got to the poster - thanks man
then I remember that forever it's like
okay did you ever use that against them
yeah but now I know how to manipulate
you guys what a bit like all right you
got the line no toy app let's go home
with a little Mike in the attitude would
be like you want that all right and then
it'd go to the swap me and get the
bootleg version I got you one bug in
blue ninja turtle bro I'm 12
you can't [ __ ] do this to me right
now I know what you're doing it does get
hard though cuz sometimes you just want
to see your kid happy and then you're
like oh [ __ ] but I don't want to I don't
want to breathe like mold this person to
be entitled in the future or whatever at
the end I'm like listen everyone's
[ __ ] up for some reason everyone's
parents [ __ ] them up for some reason so
I can actually rich kids dude rich kids
get [ __ ] up by the rich parents you
know it's crazy or like the baby that
gets like babied and she gets whatever
he or she gets whatever she wants that's
the worst
yet that's gonna
and every person's definition of babying
is also different yeah that's true I'm
talking about the girl that spoiled dad
never says no guess whatever she wants
and in Chinese credit card yeah and then
she goes into relationships expecting
the dude to treat her like that
tell me girl so I have a family member I
want to be it's just tea hmm okay this
should become a stripper
no listen is her name crystal de Luna
okay
it's kind of messed up but I have a
family member who she was the love child
okay she wasn't my child which made me
her mom was the side chick of her dead
oh [ __ ] we're married okay okay so her
dad was married then that's when the my
family member was born and this girl she
was absolutely spoiled to the max
because her dad made a lot of money so
he would always give her a ton of money
like name like brand name stuff all this
stuff and her mom because she was the
youngest out of four kids that's what
like she was the baby so she would
always like the mom would try to give
her whatever she could as well and it
was kind of like a competition with them
with the dad and the mom because the dad
still stayed with his family so he was
still a married man the wife knew and
everything so I think like for the mom
she was kind of competing for this
little girls love so that turned into a
mess because now fast forward she's an
adult
she has schizophrenia she has bipolar
issues and she's also a meth head
oh she I think she does heroin too she
has two kids who she doesn't raise and
her kids have like genetic disorders
because of all the drugs she did
she's hot to the Seas real hot yeah so
she she did the same thing where she was
a she was she created love children of
her own with married men or something
now what happened well she just popped
out kids like with random drug guys
pretty much but the thing when does she
become a prostitute she didn't sounds
like it was on her way well she's trying
to get help and it's really hard because
of her mental issues like it's hard to
like help her cuz she like runs away
all the time but the point is that I've
kind of observed from a third-person
perspective is that by these two parents
being so selfish trying to like like I
don't know throw their [ __ ] on to
this child it created this this [ __ ]
rollercoaster they had a cold war with
each other through the kid yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah there's a lot of
situations like that I know I try don't
blame [ __ ] batshit crazy people or
problematic people or whatever it's like
people don't see the generational
influences or everything they just see
it as they think it's that one human
beings choice yeah a lot of the times
are just programmed a certain way
hell yeah like my tea for some of the
times like I just think they even like a
girl who's raised right can become a
prostitute yeah I would agree to that
too yeah well yeah
[Music]
[Music]